السلام عليكم لدى اللقاء برئيسه منظمه
مجاهدي خلق الايرانيه المعارضه مريم في
باريس قال احمد الجربه رئيس الائتلاف
السوري المعارض ان مصير الثوره السوريه
مرتبط بمصير الشعب الايراني وممثله الشرعي
المقاومه الايرانيه واضاف ان السوريين
والايرانيين يقاتلان نفس العدو نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
اي دلاله للقاء الجربه ورجوي في ضوء دعم
طهران سياسيا وميدانيا للنظام الاسد
واي انعكاسات لهذا التنسيق على خريطه
المواقف الدوليه الاقليميه تجاه الثوره
السوريه
بين من يعتبر لقاء باريس بين احمد الجربه
ومريم رجاوي بالاستراتيجي ومن يعتبره خطوه
من الائتلاف السوري المعارض في اتجاه
التصعيد مع ايران تبقى طهران في قلب كل
النقاشات بشان مال الثوره السوريه بعد ان
اظهرت خريطه المواقف السياسيه وتطورات
الاحداث الميدانيه ان جزءا من مسار هذه
الثوره وقدرها يتحدد كل يوم عبر العوامل
الاقليميه وفي صداقتها ايران
وتصوراتها للحل في سوريا واسلوبها في
صياغه هذا الحل والدفع نحوه
علامات استفهام كثيره تحيط بمغزى وتداعيات
لقاء الرئيس الائتلاف السوري المعارض احمد
الجربه في باريس برئيسه المجلس الوطني
للمقاومه الايرانيه وتنظيم مجاهد خلق مريم
رجاوي وبزمان ومكان اللقاء في غمره الظروف
السوريه الراهنه صحيح ان الجانبين يلتقيان
عند الموقف ضد النظام الايراني والسياساته
غير ان منطلقاتهما ومشاريعهما تبقى مختلفه
وهو ما جعل لافتا ذلك الحديث عن ان مصير
الشعب والثوره السوريه مرتبط بمصير الشعب
والمعارضه الايرانيه ممثله في مجلس
المقاومه الذي تتزعمه مريم رجاوي كانت
منظمه خلق وفي مراحل كثيره منذ تاسيسها
قبل نحو 50 سنه ككيان معارض للحكم في
ايران مثيره للجدل خاصه فيما يتعلق
باتهامها بالارهاب لكنها ظلت تنفيذ ذلك
بشده بل افلحت في اغناع اوروبا وامريكا
رفع اسمها من لائحه المنظمات الارهابيه
لكن ذلك لم يقضي على توجسات الدبلوماسيه
الدوليه المحيطه بها والحرج الذي يسببه
الاعتراف في نشاطها للغرب في حواره
المتطاول مع ايران خاصه في عهد الاصلاحيين
الراهن ليس ذلك فحسب بل ان لقاء باريس يرى
وفي الذهن تحفظات طالما انطلقت من قاده
داخل الائتلاف الوطني تحذر من التداعيات
السالبه لدعم الجماعات المسلحه المتعدده
الاسماء للثوره السوريه مما يطرح بهاحاح
تعريف الائتلاف الباحث وبشده عن دعم الغرب
وغيرهم لاي شكل من اشكال التعاون مع مجاهد
خلق بل كيف ينظر اصدقاء سوريا حلفاء
المعارضه والثوره الذين استضافتهم لندن
اخيرا وتعهدوا بزياده الدعم للمعارضه
السوريه لشكل ومستقبل وتفاصيل مثل هذا
التعاون وتبقى في النهايه مطروحه كل
الاسئله الجدليه حول ما يمكن ان تقدمه
منظمه مجاهدي خلق للائتلاف الوطني السوري
حاليا ويعين على انتصار الثوره على نظام
الاسد
ثم ما يمكن ان تقدمه الثوره السوريه عند
انتصارها للمعارضه الايرانيه في ظل
التعقيدات المعروفه التي تحكم السياسات
والاستراتيجيات المحليه والاقليميه
والدوليه
معنا في هذه الحلقه من طهران الدكتور هادي
الفقهي الدبلوماسي الايرانيه السابق من
اسطنبول زياد حسن عضو الهيئه السياسيه
ومن باريس الدكتور خطاب ابو دياب الباحث
في المعهد الدولي للدراسات الجو سياسيه
اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا نبدا بالسيد زياد حسن
في اسطنبول
ما الهدف من وراء هذا اللقاء مع السيده
رجاويه
الحقيقه هذا اللقاء مع السيده
رجوي ليس اللقاء الاول الذي يجمع بين
الائتلاف الوطني السوري ومنظمه مجاهدي خلق
هذا اللقاء هو اللقاء الثاني بعد ان التقى
بهم الاستاذ بدر جاموس الامين العام
للائتلاف الوطني السوري وقد كانت كان
اللقائين يهدفان الى التنسيق بين الائتلاف
الوطني السوري بين المعارضه السوريه
والمعارضه الايرانيه بشكل عام وذلك من اجل
الوقوف من اجل الوقوف ضد غطرسه النظام
الايراني الذي لا يقف عند حدود ايران بل
تجاوز ذلك الى دول المنطقه برمتها واصبح
بؤره للفساد في هذه المنطقه لذلك
كما تعلمون بان
منظمه مجاهدين خلقه هي منظمه معارضه
للنظام المجرم في ايران وكذلك نحن نقاوم
نظام بشار الاسد الذي يعتبر نظام الايراني
الداعم الاساسي له في هذه المنطقه لذلك
نريد ان نبدا علاقات جديده مع منظمه
مجاهدي خلق من اجل البحث في كيفيه دعمهم
للثوره السوريه والمعارضه السوريه في
نضالها ضد النظام الايراني
وذراعها التنفيذيه في سوريا المتمثله
ببشار الاسد وعصابتها الحاكمه
هذا هو الهدف بعد اذنك سيد زياد طالما هذا
الهدف نريد ان نعرف من الدكتور هادئ فقهي
عما
عما اذا كان مثل هذا الكلام هو نفس ما
استقبلت به طهران دلاله اللقاء بين الجربه
والرجوي
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
في الحقيقه لم تعر ايران اهميه لهذا
اللقاء ولا لسابقاته من اللقاءات الاخرى
ولا لقائهم الارهابي لانهم المنظمتين
والمكونين في الحقيقه هما ارهابين وداعمين
للارهاب فمنظمه منافقين خلق اعترفوا من
خلال بيانات الرسميه على وسائل الاعلام
العالميه انه تبنو كثير من التفجيرات ومن
العمليات الارهابيه من اغتيالات رئيس
الجمهوريه ورئاسه الوزراء تفجير الحزب
الجمهوري وملف يعني حافل بالجرائم
والجوسسه والارهاب والخطف والتفجيرات
حوالي 15 الف شهيد قضوا على ايدي منظمه
منافقي خلق الارهابيه
فاليوم نحن نشاهد هذا اللقاء علنا في حين
انه هذا اللقاء كان يعني كما اشار ضيفك
المؤدب جدا من اسطنبول اشار انه كانت هناك
لقاءات وحتى اعترفت يعني من خلال تقرير
الاوفيجارو ان هناك اشياء لمنافق خلق بين
القتلى في اطراف ريف ادلب فهذا التعاون في
الحقيقه وهذا اللقاء نحن نعتبره لقاء
خاسرين سواء كان الائتلاف السوري او منظمه
منافقين خال ولكن سيدنا
بعد اذنك بعد اذنك اشارتك للطرفين على
انهما
ارهابيان هذا التصنيف لا يبدو معتمدا
دوريا لا يبدو معتمدا دوليا لا بالنسبه
للمجاهدين خلق ولا بالنسبه للائتلاف
السوري المعارض
لا بالعكس منافق يخلق الى قبل سنتين كانوا
على لائحه الارهاب الامريكيه وكذلك جميع
الدول الاوروبيه فما عدم ما بدا اصبحت
الان خارج هذا هذه القائمه السوداء لانهم
يفصلون الارهاب حسب مصالحهم ولا يعطون
تعريفا اكاديميا كلاسيكي للارهاب كي نعرف
ان الائتلاف الوطني هو ارهابي او غير
ارهابي او منافقين خلع الذين يعترفون
باختيار رئيس جمهوريه منتخب ورئيس وزراء
ومجموعه كوكبه من ممثلي البرلمان و15 الف
شهيد
هذا يتعلق
بحصيله مجاهدي خلق في الداخل الايراني
ولكن هذا اللقاء سيد الدكتور خطاب ابو
دياب هل فيه هل فيه شبهه النكايه اكثر مما
فيه من الجدوى السياسيه
من الجدول السياسيه
ايضا
نحن امام معادله تقليديه عدو وعدوه صديقي
من ناحيه اخرى في مساله التصنيف الارهابي
اتذكر انه عندما وصل الرئيس الايراني
السابق محمد خاتمي
يومها بدات اوروبا الحوار تحت عنوان
الحوار النقدي قبل ذلك كان هناك ارهاب
للنظام في طهران وكان هناك
اتهامات باغتيال معرضين وابرزهم القائد
الكردي في برلين وعمليات اخرى اذا فتحنا
ملفات من هذا النوع بالنسبه لاختلاف
السوري الاتلاف السوري بالذات هو الضحيه
وضحيه المشروع الامبراطوري الايراني كما
هو ضحيه نظام الاسد الشعب السوري كله ضحيه
تم تحويل بلاده الى ساحه كما يحق لايران
ان تتعامل مع معارضين سوريين معينين كما
يحق لايران ان تدافع عن مصالحها وترسل
الاف المقاتلين المؤلفه من محورها لت مجرى
المعركه في سوريا يحق على الاقل للائتلاف
السوري ان يلعب في صحته ويحاول ايضا
التنسيق مع قوه تعارض هذا النظام لان
النظام الايراني خاض معركه البقاء عندما
تكلم عن سوريا انها المحافظه الايرانيه
الخمسه وتلاتين كان يقصد بانه اذا سقط
النظام في دمشق سيكون ذلك مفتاح سقوط
النظام في طهران اذا هناك تلازم مصالح
واللعبه الايرانيه في بلاد الشام وضد
العالم العربي لعبه هذا النظام لعبه قويه
لا احد ينكر اهميه التوجه الجديد لروحاني
وامكانيه الانفتاح العربي الايراني لكن
عندما نرى الافكار الايرانيه حول سوريا
والانعطاف الايرانيه في العراق او في
لبنان نفهم جيدا بان الانفتاح الروحاني في
الملف النووي لم يترجم حتى الان على
الصعيد الع لاقات الخارجيه
ان نعم عفوا حوار الجربه مع رجل عامل ضغط
في هذا الاتجاه يعني اشرت الى تلازم او
التقاء المصالح هنا نسال سيد زياد حسن
عمليا ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه هذه المعارضه
الايرانيه
للمعارضه السوريه مع الاخذ بالاعتبار
الاشاره التي قالها قبل قليل ضيفنا من
طهران بان كان هناك رفات لمقاتلين من
مجاهدي خلق في ادلب الى اي مدى هذا صحيح
الحقيقه هذا اللقاء بين الائتلاف الوطني
ومنظمه مجاهدين خلق المعارضه في ايران جاء
كان لقاء متاخرا جدا كان يجب على الائتلاف
الوطني ومنظمه مجاهديه خلق ان يجلسوا على
الطاوله منذ زمن بعيد لاننا ندافع عن نفس
القيم التي يدافعون عنها نحن نبحث عن
الحريه والكرامه لشعبنا وكذلك هذه المنظمه
تبحث عن حريه وكرامه الشعب الايراني الذي
تصرف دولتهم مليارات الدولارات من اجل نشر
الارهاب والفساد في سوريا وفي دعمها
للنظام المجرم في سوريا فيما يتضوروا
الشعب الايراني جوعا نحن من خلال هذا
اللقاء بدانا نبحث عن صيغ للتعاون
والتنسيق بيننا وبين مجاهدين خلق وهنا
اريد ان اشير الى الملاحظه التي اوردها
ضيفكم من طهران نحن لا تلزمنا جنود ولا
تلزمنا رجال من خارج سوريا فرجالات سوريا
ومجاهدون سوريا وثوار سوريا قادرون على
الدفاع عنها والجيش السوري الحر يلتزم
بالدفاع عن سوريا نحن بحاجه الى
دعم مادي ودعم في العتاد التقينا مع هذه
المنظمه لعلها تكون
قادره على دعمنا في نضالنا ضد هذا النظام
المجرم اما مساله الرفاه التي يتحدث عنها
ضيفكم من طهران والتي يقول انهم وجدوها في
ادلب فانا متيقن تماما بانها رفاه
لميليشيات حزب الله اللبنانيه
وميليشيات ابو الفضل العباس وغيرها من
العصابات المسلحه التي ارسلتها ايران من
اجل من اجل قتل الشعب السوري ونشر الارهاب
في دولتنا وفي وطننا سوريا طلب اشرت الى
ان المعارضه السوريه والمعارضه الايرانيه
يحاربان من اجل نفس القيم ويحاربان نفس
العدو في هذه الحاله الدكتور هادئه فقير
هل
تعتقدون بان طبيعه الموقف الايراني مما
يجري في سوريا اعطى المجال لهذه المعارضه
ان تقحم نفسها في ملف بغرض ارباك طهران في
ملف خارجي اذا كانت عاجزه عن ارباكها في
ملف داخلي
يا سيدي يعني لا يوجد الان هناك شيء اسمه
منظمه منافق لخلق يعني هي اندثرت وراحت
ولم يبقى الا افراد قليلين في معسكر
ليبرتي قريب مطار بغداد الدولي بعد ان
يعني حاربهم ورماهم الشعب العراقي
بالحجاره من معسكر اشرف الذي كان مغصوب
ارض هذه المنطقه من الفلاحين والمزارعين
العراقيين في منطقه ديالا
ولكن هذا بالاساس ربما قام به انصار السيد
المالكي الذي هو محسوب اصلا على على ايران
هذا رايكم انا اعطي رايي وكل له راي هو
يبدي رايه بحريه سيدي تفضل فشاركوا
المنافقين في قتل الاكراد في منطقه حرب
الانفال عندما كان صدام المعدوم يقاتل
ويقتل الشعب الكردي فاذا منظمه منافقي خلق
يعني اصبحت الان بندقيه للايجار يوما عن
صدام المعدوم يوما عند السعوديين والان
عند الموساد وعنده غيرهم فلم يبقى الا
اعداد قليله جدا في معسكر ليبرتي وما يسمى
المجلس الوطني القومي لمنافقين خلق
ويتاجرون بهذه الدعايات ويتجسسون على
شعرهم وعلى مصالح شعبهم لصالح العدو
الاسرائيلي وغيرهم على كل فيما يتعلق بهذا
اللقاء نريد ان نعرف بعد الفاصل ان كانت
هناك انعكاسات او ايه ابعاد مستقبليه لمثل
هذا اللقاء بين رجوي وجربه على طبيعه
المواقف الاقليميه والدوليه من الملف
السوري لنا عوده بعد هذا الفاصل نرجو ان
تبقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد ودلالات
لقاء الجربه ومريم رجوي مؤخرا سيد زياد
حسن اذا اخذنا بعض المواقف المتعلقه مما
يجري في في سوريا الان نلاحظ ان مساعد
وزير الخارجيه الايراني كان في زياره
قريبه الى
قطر وتحدث عن تغير في الموقف القطري يتحدث
عن تنسيق مع تركيا
وبالتالي هو يشير الى ان هناك علاقات
جديده تبنى مع طهران في الملف السوري وان
الوحيد الباقيه خارج هذا التنسيق كما يقول
حسب تعبيره هي السعوديه في هذه الحاله الا
يبدو انكم تسيرون عكس التيار الاقليمي
المتعلق بترتيب الوضع في سوريا
سيدي العزيز كانت هناك لقاءات قريبه جدا
في فتره قريبه جدا بين قيادات الائتلاف
الوطني السوري وكل الدول التي تحدثتم عنها
القيادات القطريه والسعوديه والتركيه هناك
تنسيق كامل بين الائتلاف الوطني السوري
بين المعارضه السوريه وبين هذه الدول
اعتقد بان الدول الاقليميه الداعمه
والصديقه للشعب السوري في ثورته ضد اله
الظلم في سوريا تحاول ان تثني النظام
الايراني عن مواقفه المعاديه للشعب السوري
وهي في هذا الاطار تلتقي مع القيادات
الايرانيه لعلها تستطيع ان تسنيها كما
اسلفت عما تذهب اليه منذ عده سنوات في قتل
الشعب السوري انا لا اعتقد بان هناك حاله
من الاتجاه او السير عكس التيار لدى
الائتلاف الوطني السوري بالعكس قياده
الاتلاف ورئيس الائتلاف الان في السعوديه
وكان هناك لقاءات مع القياده التركيه منذ
فتره ليست بالبعيده نحن على ضوء وهم
يضعوننا في ضوء جميع هذه اللقاءات التي
تجري نحن نامل بان تعود ايران من خلال هذه
بعد هذه اللقاءات عن عن دعمها لنظام
الارهاب والتها التنفيذيه في سوريا
المتمثله بنظام بشار الاسد والته القمعيه
ولكن لا يمكن الدكتور خطاب الا يمكن ان
ينظر اصدقاء سوريا كما يسمون بعين الريبه
لمثل هذا اللقاء على اساس ان الائتلاف
المعارض يفتح خط مع المعارضه الايرانيه
وقد لا يكون هذا في حساب هذه الدول وهي
تدعم الثوره السوريه
بالطبع لو كانت منظمه مجاهدين خلق لا تزال
مصنفه كما كانت منذ فتره لم يكن لهذا
اللقاء ان يحصل هذا اللقاء حسب علمي حصل
بعلم مباشره او غير مباشره لمجموعه اصدقاء
سوريا بمعنى ان هذه الحركه الدبلوماسيه
منسقه كما قلت كما يحق للنظام للقياده
الايرانيه ان تجري حوار مع تركيا مع مصر
مع قطر مع دول كثيره حول الملف السوري
ربما غدا مع السعوديه ببساطه السلطنه عمان
كيف لا يمكن ايضا الائتلاف السوري المعارض
ان يتحرك دبلوماسيا كان هناك اجتماع منذ
فتره للوعد المعارضين السوريين من خارج
الائتلاف وكان هناك هذا الاجتماع في
القاهره السيد معاذ الخطيب السيد هيثم
مناع وغيرهم وكان هناك فكره ان يذهبوا الى
طهران اذا اللعبه مفتوحه كل يحاول ان يلعب
في موقع الاهم انه من خلال ما قاله
الابراهيمي قبل رحيله حول موضوع
الاقتراحات الايرانيه صدر بعد ذلك ورقه
ايرانيه اخرى لا تتكلم حتى عن تقليص
صلاحيات الرئيس في سوريا وتحاول بشكل او
باخر تكريس انتصار النظام الورقه
الايرانيه في الماضي حاولت القياده
الايرانيه ايضا عبر تركيا اقناع جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين في سوريا بالتعامل مع
النظام وبتاليف حكومه معه كان هناك رفض
لهذه الفكره وذلك في عام 2011 المساله
قديمه محاوله جعل كل شيء من خلال القبضه
الايرانيه الان هذا العمل من قبل الائتلاف
هو محاوله معاكسه لان الضغط العسكري
الايراني من خلال حزب الله من خلال فضل
العباس وصل بايران الامر لتجديد لاجئين
افغان ولاجئين باكستانيين واي من دول اخرى
للمجيء في القتال في سوريا الكل ينظر فقط
الى جهاد من نوع اخر في سوريا يتكلم عن
شيشائره لكن لا يتكلم عن الاخرين هناك
فعلا ظلم كبير للشعب السوري الذي حولت
ارضه الى ساحه مفتوحه لكل الصراعات اول
صراع دولي متعدد الاقطاب اول كارثه كبرى
ولذلك يحقن الائتلاف ان يدافع عن نفسه قدر
الامكان وسط هذه المعطيات الصعبه جدا ولكن
رغم ان ضيفنا في طهران يعتبر بان هذا
اللقاء طهران لم تعره اي اهتمام واصلا
مجاهدي خلق لا يمثلون اي شيء رغم ذلك
دكتور افقي الا تعتقدون بان رغم كل ذلك قد
يكون هذا اللقاء اشاره لطهران حتى تسرع من
وتيره تحركها لمعالجه سياسيه لملف سوريا
حتى لا تصل نيران
الازمه السوريه الى ثيابها حتى وان كانت
بشكل محدود
يعني هل كانت اخ محمد تنتظر طيران هذا
اللقاء كي تقوم بدورها السياسي والبناء
انا قلت انا قلت سره تسرع تسرع من وتيره
لا اقول بدات ان كان ذلك
لاستقبال كل المناوين والمعارضين
السياسيين للنظام السوري لحل هذه الملف
وهذه الازمه عن طريق الحوار السياسي وما
التقارب واللقاءات
الدافعه الان بين ايران وبين قطر الا على
هذا السبيل وعلى هذا المسار
وحتى نحن الان في انتظار استقبال امير قطر
يحلله الازمه السوريه ما دور منافقي خلقه
وما دور الوطني الذي هم في الحقيقه طيعه
وادوات بيد هذا وذاك هذه الدول الان
تتعامل لحل هذه الازمه دول الكبرى خذ من
امريكا وروسيا الى الدول الاقليميه وسنشهد
التقارب السعودي الايراني لحل هذه الازمه
ايران صبت كل جهدها لحل هذه الازمه عن
طريق الحوار السياسي والتفاهم من اقصى
اليمين المتطرف سياسيا والائتلاف استعدت
ايران لاستقبالهم الى اقصى اليسار فما هو
وما هو الشان ووزن منافق او غيرهم كتحسب
ايران او تسرع في العمليه السياسيه اشرت
الى زياره محتمله قريبه لامير قطر الى
طهران وهناك ايضا زياره قريبه لوزير
الخارجيه الايراني الى السعوديه في هذه
الحاله في نهايه الحلقه سيد زياد حسن هل
تعتقدون في النهايه بان هذا اللقاء في
النهايه قد لا يكون ذي وزن بالنظر الى
اتصالات الجميع مع طهران وليس مع
المعارضين لطهران
سيدي العزيز بدايه عطفا على كلام ضيفكم من
ايران انا اريد ان اذكر فقط بان ما يجري
في سوريا الان هو عباره عن ثوره ثوره شعب
انطلق انطلق من اجل حريته وكرامته ونحن من
ناحيه مبدئيه نتفق مع جميع حركات التحرر
في العالم ضد قوه الظلم والطغيان بغض
النظر عن قوه هذه الحركات وبغض النظر عن
امكانياتها كانت قويه ام ضعيفه هذا اولا
اما بالعوده الى سؤالكم اريد ان اقول بان
الائتلاف الوطني السوري
يسعى جاهدا بان تحلل الازمه السوريه
الثوره السوريه لصالح الشعب السوري ولصالح
كرامه وحريه الشعب السوري لذلك اعتقد بان
هذا اللقاء كان لقاء هاما وسوف تتلوه
لقاءات اخرى مع اطراف معارضه اخرى في
ايران اعتقد بان لها دور ووزن شعبي كبير
ايضا في الدوله الايرانيه ايران تقوم بصرف
المليارات من الدولارات وايران الان تعاني
من ازمه حقيقيه في اقتصادها الداخلي هي
تريد الخروج من هذه الازمه من خلال اقناع
الدول الاقليميه الداعمه للشعب السوري
والصديقه الشعب السوري من خلال اقناعها في
سياساتها وفي توجهاتها العدوانيه ضد الشعب
السوري وهذا ما لا يحدث لصالح ايران
واعتقد بان الشعب السوري سوف تنتصر بالرغم
من كل الدعم الايراني الذي تقدمه لنظامها
المجرم في سوريا شكرا لك زياد حسن عضو
الهيئه السياسيه للاعتلاف الوطني السوري
شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من طهران الدكتور هادئ
الفقيه الدبلوماسي الدبلوماسي الايراني
السابق وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من باريس
الدكتور خطار ابو دياب الباحث في المعهد
الدولي للدراسات الجيو السياسيه
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نصل الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه في امان الله